más de un siglo de exilio dos años de
negociaciones con parís y tres meses
después de su regreso a venir las 26
horas del reino de a gómez finalmente se
exhiben en el palacio presidencial en
cotonou en vísperas de la apertura al
público el jefe de estado- beninés quien
negoció la restitución como una
prioridad desde su elección en 2016
entregó las obras a los descendientes de
dignatarios de los antiguos reinos de
benin
causalidad
pedimos más obras pero fue parís quien
eligió no vamos a pedir que se devuelva
todo las obras beninesas deben
permanecer en los museos de todo el
mundo para que el planeta pueda ver la
grandeza de venir
como las tesoros saqueados en 1892 por
las tropas coloniales francesas del
palacio de a gómez en el centro de benin
pero el país quiere seguir recuperando
otras obras un mensaje recibido por la
ministra de cultura francesa presente en
la inauguración para roselyne bachelot
francia debe como desea de manuel macrón
desempeñar su papel en la reapropiación
de los africanos de su patrimonio de la
voluntad
es la voluntad de escribir otra historia
de recrear a partir de este patrimonio
memorial histórico y estético y vemos
artistas benineses absolutamente
notables y estoy bien y nos abstuvimos
los cables
de hecho 34 artistas contemporáneos se
exponen junto a las obras restauradas
para ilustrar la continuidad de la
riqueza cultural de benin